c'est une affaire qui fait grand bruit
ici à bois mais dont on ne sait que peu
de choses aujourd'hui tout commence en
race campagne à quelques kilomètres de
Blois nous sommes mardi il est 23h une
patrouille de gendarmerie remarque une
camionnette stationnée aux abords du
village de Saint-Lubin en vergonnois les
gendarmes s'apprêtent à contrôler ce
véhicule suspect mais la camionnette
démarre et prend la fuite le véhicule
sans bourbe alors dans un chemin de
terre et son conducteur s'évapore dans
la camionnette les gendarmes découvrent
vous le savez deux cadavres il s'agirait
de deux personnes originaires de
l'agglomération orléanaise l'un d'eux
est en connu pour des faits de petites
délinquance d'après une source proche de
l'enquête les deux hommes auraient bien
été tués par bal durant 24 heures les
gendarmes ont mis en place un gros
dispositif pour rechercher le suspect
dans la campagne blezoise et la forêt
domaniale durant sa cavale le suspect
aurait trouvé refuge dans un abri de
jardin à lande-le gaulois et puis hier
coup de théâtre vers 23 heures l'homme
se rend de lui-même au groupement de
gendarmerie du Loir-et-Cher il est
aujourd'hui en garde à vue question le
suspect interpellé est-il l'auteur de ce
double homicide ou comptait-il emmener
les corps et surtout que comptait-il
faire de ces deux victimes